Yeah.
It just,
it though the hole.
I mean,
the,
the newer thing is very,
it's very interesting.
It's very interesting because you're watching a professional look,
cast a web like nice and slow,
nice and slow with the full force of the FBI against you.
And if the they it against her rod just don't,
like I said,
they'll do,
you know.
Yeah.
It's creepy.
Well,
Jamie said they opened up the government today to distract from the fact that
Roger Stone got arrested.
Most likely.
I think you're right.
I think that's a good assessment,
I guess.
I mean,
Trump's the final target,
so,
um,
but yeah,
he's gonna,
he's gonna threaten stone wood,
you know,
he's like 66.
Yeah.
Threatens them with 10 years.
He's probably gonna.
Yeah.
He's kind of said enough to fucking make them sing,
but he's such a,
like Dershowitz says they don't just sing.
They,
they,
uh,
they actually,
how to Dershowitz put it.
They actually,
and I'll come up with the lyrics they create.
They don't just sing.
Yeah.
You know,
what do you think is going to happen to Trump if you had to guess
as far as this investigation?
Nothing really pass out the coffee over here.
Ah,
thank you.
Yeah.
Thanks brother.
Why do you think nothing's going to happen?
You don't say,
well,
that's not true.
I shouldn't say that because only because I think morale is pretty fucking evil
and we'll come up with something.
Well,
you know what?
Impeachment at the,
at the worst,
but where's the high crimes and misdemeanors?
What?
Well,
if there was obstruction of justice,
if there was collusion,
if there was any sort of,
if they can prove that there was some sort of concerted effort to undermine
democracy.
Yeah.
Which I don't think,
I don't think they'll get to get them.
Even with Roger Stone,
they're not charging him with collusion of conspiracy,
just lying and covering up.
They don't,
they don't have them put collusion and conspiracy.
They're lying,
covering up the,
uh,
interactions with Russians.
Right.
So what it is,
I guess that would be malicious angle.
Yeah.